several videos ago we introduced the
idea of a fourier series that i could
take a periodic function we started with
the example of this square wave and that
i could represent it as the sum of
weighted sines and cosines and then we
took a little bit of an interlude
building a building up some of our
mathematical foundations just
establishing a bunch of properties of
taking the definite integral over the
period of that of that periodic function
of sine and cosines and we established
all of these properties and now we're
going to get the benefit from
establishing all those because we're
going to start actually finding a at
least a formula for fourier coefficients
and then we can apply it to our original
square wave to see that hey this is this
could actually be a pretty
straightforward thing
so right over here i have rewritten a
fourier series expression or i've
rewritten the fourier series for a
periodic function f of t let's say its
period is 2 pi and i'm going to use this
and some of the properties that we have
established to start solving for these
for these actual coefficients and what
i'm going to do in this code in this
video i'm going to first try to solve
for a sub 0 and then in the next video
we're going to solve for an arbitrary a
sub n and either that one or the next
one will also solve for an arbitrary b
sub n
so to solve for a sub 0 what we're going
to do is take the definite integral of
both sides from 0 to 2 pi so 0 to 2 pi
dt of f of t well that's going to be the
same thing as going from 0 to 2 pi
of
all of this stuff remember this is an
infinite series right over here we have
an infinite number of terms and then we
would have a dt out there but we know
from our integration properties taking
the definite integral of a sum even an
infinite sum is the same thing as the
sum of the definite integrals so that's
going to be the same thing as taking
this integral
dt
plus
this integral and i i could take the the
scalar out actually let me not just not
do that let me just write it like this
0 to 2 pi
dt
0 to two pi
zero
to two pi
dt this is getting a little monotonous
but it'll be worth it zero to two pi
dt
zero to two pi
to 2 pi
dt and we'll do it for every single one
of the terms
and now what's nice is we can look at
our integration properties this right
over here we could take that we could
take these coefficients out we could
take this a sub 1 put it in front of the
integral sign the a sub 2 put it in
front of the integral sign the b sub 1
put it in front of the integral sign and
then all you're left with is integral
from 0 to 2 pi of cosine of some integer
multiple of t dt
well we established a couple of videos
ago well that's always going to be equal
to zero the integral from zero to two pi
of cosine of some non-zero non-zero
integer multiple of t dt that is equal
to zero and then the same thing is true
for sine of m t
so this is going to be fun
this is going to be 0 based on what we
just saw if you just take that take that
factor out of that integral take that a
sub 1 out of the integral is going to be
a sub 1 times 0. this is going to be a
sub 2 times 0 that's going to be 0.
that's going to be 0 that's going to be
0 that's going to be 0. every term is
going to be 0 except for this one
involving a sub 0.
and so what is this going to be equal to
well let me write it this way
let's take the integral of
the definite integral
let me see where i have some space so
we're going to take the definite
integral from 0 to 2 pi
of a sub 0 dt well that's the same thing
once again we could take the coefficient
out of a sub 0 and i could just put the
dt
like
i could just put the dt
like this and so that's going to be
equal to
a sub 0
times
t
let me do that in magenta
times t
evaluated at 2 pi
and 0 which is going to be equal to
a sub 0 times 2 pi minus 0
times 2 pi
minus 0 well that's just 2 pi a sub 0.
so i could just write this a sub 0
times 2 pi
so this expression right here is a sub 0
so let me scroll down a little bit so i
can rewrite this thing up here the
integral
from 0 to 2 pi
of f of t dt
f of t dt
which is equal to this integral but
we've just figured out that the integral
from 0 to 2pi of a sub 0 dt is the same
thing as a sub 0 times 2pi
is equal to
a sub 0
times 2 pi
and so now it's actually pretty straight
forward to solve for a sub 0. a sub 0 is
going to be equal to
a sub 0 is going to be equal to
1 over 2 pi 1 over 2 pi times the
definite integral from 0 to 2 pi
i'll just write the dt
of
let me write it a little bit
dt of f of t i'll just write like this f
of t
dt and this is pretty cool because think
about what this is this over here this
is the average value of our function uh
this is the average value of f over the
interval 0 to 2 pi
average
value
of f
over
the interval over we could say the
interval from 0
the interval from zero to two pi and
hopefully that actually makes intuitive
sense because if i am if you just think
of from an engineering point of view if
you're trying to engineer this trying to
just play around with these numbers you
know all these cosines and sines they
oscillate between positive 1 and
negative 1. so in order to actually
represent this function you're going to
have to shift that that oscillation and
the sum of a bunch of oscillations is
still going to be an oscillation that's
going to vary between
a positive 1 and our negative 1
and in order to shift it well that's
what our a sub 0 is going to do and so
what you it makes sense that you would
want to shift the oscillation so it
oscillates around the average value of
the function or you could say the
average value of the function over over
an interval that's that's representative
of a period of that function and so that
is what a sub 0 is doing a sub 0
is just going to be that average value
of the function